we all know that Apple has already
announced that their new arms silicon
Macs are coming later this year and that
within two years they're ditching Intel
processors for good but we just got a
new piece of news that is an even bigger
deal Apple is also ditching AMD graphics
cards just like they did to Nvidia last
year and they're moving forward
exclusively with their own custom GPUs
so in this video I'm gonna show you how
I know they're doing this I'm gonna talk
about what else they're planning on
doing I'm gonna discuss why they're
doing it and I'm gonna let you know what
this ultimately means for you and your
purchasing decisions
but before we get into it we just got a
new premium version of our classic Apple
product pattern t-shirt and this one is
incredibly soft and comfortable for just
four dollars more than our classic shirt
so definitely check it out in our merch
shelf right below this video
back to the Mac Apple has a new support
document for developers which shows off
the difference between their Apple
silicon Macs
and Intel base Macs on the Intel side it
shows support for Intel Nvidia and AMD
GPUs and if you're wondering why it says
Nvidia well there used to be Mac's with
Nvidia graphics cards the last one was
the 2014 15 inch MacBook Pro so this
basically shows that the chart is
talking about all previous Macs in
general which is a very important detail
to notice because if we go back to the
chart on the apple silicon side it
simply says apple GPU will discuss why
they would do this in what this means in
just a minute but first let's go through
the other interesting parts of the chart
it shows that the GPU architecture on
Apple's silicon Mac's
will use tile based deferred rendering
which is what they currently use on
iPhones and iPads to sum it up TBD are
significantly reduces system memory
bandwidth requirements which in turn
increases performance and reduces power
requirements so basically you get better
performance with lower memory bandwidth
and it uses less power so that means
less heat and ultimately better battery
it's basically a win-win in every aspect
of the GPU and in terms of metal api
support the chart shows that it supports
two api's mac two and apple this
basically means that apple silicon max
will support both mac OS and iOS apps
natively since they're both using
apple's metal architecture apple also
showed off the transition process in
another slide showing off how developers
will transition to fully optimizing
their apps for Apple GPUs over the next
two years
when Apple reveals their first GPUs now
I don't know if you remember but Apple
dropped support for Nvidia graphics
cards last year and now it all makes
sense why they would do that their
master plan was to eventually have
developers optimize their apps for
custom Apple silicon graphics chips so
they forced AMD and NVIDIA to support
their metal architecture so that
developers could switch their apps over
to using metal of course and Vidya
refused to do so
so Apple ultimately dropped them but AMD
agreed and they've been supporting metal
for years now which means that it's
already much easier for developers to
transition their apps over to Apple
silicon chips which run using metal so
with all that said you probably have a
lot of questions so let's start with why
Apple would want to completely ditch AMD
and Intel graphics first off is going to
be a lot cheaper for Apple since they
currently have to pay Intel and AMD for
every chip they use but they also
created a slide with four different
reasons so let's start with the first
one faster Apple believes that their own
graphics chips in the future will be
faster than the AMD graphics chips that
they're currently using now I don't know
how long that'll take but if you take a
look at the graphics performance of
Apple's iPad pro it's nearing 10,000
points in Geekbench 5s metal test and
that's a tiny chip in a very thin iPad
pro with no active cooling at all apples
base 16 inch MacBook Pro comes with a
much larger dedicated 5300 M graphics
chip which scores around 24,000 points
with active fan cooling so if Apple was
to scale that tiny iPad chip up and give
it active cooling it could easily
outperform the current AMD options
the second reason on the chart is power
efficiency it's estimated that the iPad
pro chip has a TDP of between seven and
ten watts and that's the entire chip
including the processing side compared
to 50 Watts on the 5300 M for just
graphics rendering that is extremely
efficient meaning way less power being
used way less heat output and less band
noise this is huge news for Apple since
they're 16 inch MacBook Pro is already
hitting their 100 watt total TDP limit
to ensure that users get the full
performance when unplugged so Apple is
currently hitting a performance wall in
terms of power usage and switching to
their own efficient ARM chips will give
them a ton of room to grow this
basically means that in the worst case
scenario Apple could easily make a 50
watt TDP graphics chip and get five
times more performance than the current
a 12 Z chip
therefore doubling the performance of
the AMD 5300 M once everything is
optimized and that's not even
considering that Apple silicon GPUs will
be a completely new family of chips made
using the new 5 nanometer process
instead of the current 7 nanometer
process that the a12 Z is built on the
third reason is nu-metal features for
mac OS this basically means that they
can continue to improve the features of
Mac OS while staying very efficient
which they've already started to show
off at WWDC like the new messages app
which is much more functional than
before the fourth reason is alignment
with iOS iPad OS and TV OS basically
switching back over to Apple silicon is
going to make it a whole lot easier for
Apple to develop and update their own
apps instead of having to work on iOS
and Mac OS apps separately they can do
it once and make some minor adjustments
for each platform this also means less
work for third-party developers who no
longer have to make two different apps
if they want it on both iPhone and Mac
now out of all of those reasons I think
the most important one is that Apple
will no longer be held back by Intel and
AMD s product release timeline so will
no longer see a new MacBook Pro with
basically the same graphics or processor
as last year's model Apple will finally
be able to consistently give us a
processor and graphics improvement every
single year just like they do with the
iPhone now another big question is if
Apple is gonna start making dedicated
graphics chips or stick to the ones that
are integrated into the processor like
they currently are doing with iOS
devices well if Apple is switching to
arm and ditching both Intel processors
and AMD graphics they're gonna do it
everywhere including the Mac Pro and the
Mac Pro needs to have incredibly
powerful graphics performance and to do
this they'll most likely have to
separate the graphics from the ARM
processor so we should expect Apple to
make some form of dedicated graphics
chips now whether they'll be removable
is another question but this ultimately
means that they could also separate the
ARM chips in the MacBook Pro for example
to have a high-powered dedicated
graphics chip so with all of that said
let's get to the final point what does
all of this mean for you well if you
want your third-party apps to work great
you should probably wait to upgrade to
an apple silicon arm Mac until your apps
are finally proven to be fully optimized
for Apple's GPUs this might take two or
three or even more years depending on
how actively your developer of your
much-needed app upgrades and optimizes
it for new technology so in that case it
might be a good idea to buy an Intel
based Mac right now like the 16 inch
MacBook Pro on sale using the link below
and enjoy optimized AMD graphics
performance for the next couple of years
before you finally buy an ARM based Mac
now what this also means is that each EP
you support is most likely going away on
Apple silicon Macs or at least a GPUs
with AMD graphics Apple will probably
create their own custom
Apple II GPU in the future but if you
like the idea of using an EZ PU for
gaming on Windows 10 through bootcamp
absolutely do not upgrade to an ARM
based Mac later this year stick with an
Intel based system like the 13-inch
MacBook Pro which performs very well
when connected to an e GPU but
eventually you're gonna have to switch
over to an apple silicon Mac and
hopefully by then more game developers
will be encouraged to bring some really
great games over to the Mac OS platform
and in general the switch to Apple GPUs
means that your future MacBook or iMac
or any Mac is gonna be more powerful
thanks to metal optimization while
running a lot cooler and quieter and
don't forget the better battery life so
while this might seem a little
disappointing right now everyone is
gonna win in the end if you disagree
with my point of view go ahead and let
me know down in the comments section
below and if you learn something new
from this video go ahead and click the
circle above to subscribe right now and
be sure to check out our Apple product
pattern merch right below this video
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
[Music]